I don't think it's the biggest problem  but it certainly is a problem in  relationships today that is a problem  the biggest problem with men today is  that I think the world is becoming hyper  competitive most men are not aware and  understanding of how quickly there's  going to be a genuine shift in between  those who have things and those who do  not have things not just finances but  also female status everything else and  it's a status game right and it's  becoming harder and harder for men to  play and that's all women's fault of  course  because nobody is because women choose  the winners right women choose who the  high status males are so women pretend  to give a [ __ ] about men of course they  don't they give a [ __ ] about themselves